across the prison campus inmate Jill
Nuland is a first timer to the prison
and hers is not a typical criminal
background and this place makes her
anxious I just didn't know what I was
coming into it was the unknown it was
really scary you're mixed in more
flavors you're mixed time with all
different people the 34 year old grew up
in a middle-class suburb of Baltimore
attended college and led a comfortable
life until she got hooked on painkillers
it just escalated I ran out of
prescription medication so I went to
other things I started experimenting
with heroin cocaine things like that
Jill soon found herself disappearing for
days into Baltimore drug houses
people were dealing drugs out of the
house constantly people in and out in
and out probably up to 60 to 70 people
in the house at a time
it's just crazy where drugs lead you she
eventually turned to crime to support
her habit convicted of first degree
burglary Jill got an eight-year sentence
but was put on probation she violated
her probation and is now doing hard time
prison is tough enough for first-timers
but for Jill it's proving even harder
she was three months pregnant when
coming to prison but then found out she
is having twins when she arrived I
didn't know I was having twins so I got
down here so it was a joyful cage and
then it was sad I'm a girl we're gonna
name him Savannah hope and the boy is
gonna be Jacob Jill already has a
three-year-old daughter and a
one-year-old son both of whom live with
her husband my two at home I don't
really talk about them much like a sore
subject because it's I sit there and
it's it's hard to deal with yeah one day
I was there next day I'm gone
I really wasn't me and a good mom
because a good mom doesn't get high in
this prison pregnant inmates are treated
like everyone else currently they'd have
a whole little pregnancy area and like
you know just I thought it would be
different not really mixed in with
general population I was nervous about
that at first because I was thinking if
there was a fight you know it's very
easy for me to you know get funked in -
anything could happen and yeah that
scared me
I mean you have to watch yourself
because she is carrying twins
Jill's pregnancy is considered a
high-risk twins are offering premature
and her past drug use could compromise
the baby's health as her due date nears
the prison has confined Jill to the
infirmary
a small wing separate from the main
housing units security cameras monitor
these women 24/7 in case something goes
wrong I'm really concerned about their
health I mean I think their health is
good but it's a little scary because you
don't know I mean I won't know until the
babies are born I was actually closer
it's getting worse but I can't do
anything about it so just try to deal
with it I have to take it one day at a
time
and just hope for the best but Jill will
have to deal with far more than she
expects in the days to come
[Music]
you